Film Courage: What’s your process for developing
characters?
How do you go about it?
Dr. Ken Atchity, Author/Producer: Well the
character kind of develops itself.
Basically what you do when you are dealing
with that is kind of like a checklist rather
than you’re developing the character, you
are letting the character develop himself
but you say…she has to have the following
things.
What’s her problem for example?
Is that clear?
Because if that is not clear your story is
not going to hook the audience.
What is her problem interfering with?
I call this mission in life like usually it’s
her motivation in the story (her problem)
is interfering with her mission in life.
She is somebody who wants to become a nurse
but something violent happens in the opening
scene and it seems to make her if you want
to save this person you have to do something
violent back and therefore her motivation
if she is going to save this person interferes
with her mission and those are kind of two
parts of the checklist and you go on to to
talk about how does she change (this is called
her arc).
What is the arc of her change?
How is she different at the end of the story
because a lot of times we are covering stories
that are submitted to us.
Well you know the characters don’t change.
She’s exactly the way she was at the end
that she is at the beginning.
So why?
We don’t get off on that.
We are not satisfied by a story where the
characters don’t change.
So these are kind of checklists that you apply
to characters once you get them going starting
with that intriguing situation and then adding
along the way by just checking them against
traditional characters that work well.